happy Monday reject nation you know our
names so okay yeah bunch of boxes we're
moving out of here gotta be out of here
by the end of the month
it's Monday put up our Game of Thrones
Season 1 I know season 8 episode 1
reaction this morning and I wanted to
talk about some of the response that's
happened no not just directly to there's
not reaction hate comments are not gonna
read through the comments and whatever
that's why I didn't put that we're doing
that in the title because first off
there's a reason I read the comments and
normally actually when it comes to
anything that has a passionate fandom I
tend to not read the comments in those
videos stuff like Star Wars any of our
Game of Thrones trailer reactions things
like that just because I know what it's
like to get sucked into the wormhole of
darkness and not everyone in every
fandom is it is toxic I am well aware of
that but we all know that anything with
passion usually breeds some kind of
toxicity in the way we communicate with
one another we detest to not attack
problems we tend to attack people I just
I just generally don't like doing that
and as even though I'm doing this for
several years after a while some every
once in a while there's something that
will just get to you still have all
these emotions it's so much easier said
than done cuz you know that phrase is
you just haven't done that often I might
say that to of course people love just
listen to pay attention if your video
has more likes than dislikes if it has
more likes and dislikes that means
you're doing something right you know
whatever advice that people always throw
my way and then I throw people's way
sometimes when I'm on the receiving end
I have a hard time remembering that too
I am human just like everyone else so
what what just happened was I was
feeling like my brain was all scattered
and I was like we shot a sketch that
we're gonna put up later this month and
we wanted it to be the last sketch we
shot in this apartment so I was up
editing and very late last night
we hired an editor Eric and nerd pranic
to do the edit the Game of Thrones cut
down for us and the reason I read the
comments the reason I went to the
comments was strictly because we shot it
differently and we have an editor is the
first time we've ever asked someone to
edit for us so I literally went there
not to read the comments on what people
think of what they thought of that we're
testing out right now not one comment
about the editing instead I got sucked
into the world of damn here it is then I
put out a community post and I wanna I
kind of want to go over that because I
did edit it but I will bluntly bring up
what I first put that had a bit of a
negative backlash I'm just I'm gonna saw
a couple of people comment on it but
just in case you read it and if it
rubbed you the wrong way if you
misunderstood I did want to clarify that
and you know just talked about some
other stuff some specifics of what
happened with the with the video and the
hate that was there but um first off I
feel like this community poster was
gonna go over it's one thing it's gonna
flash on screens uncut video because I
want to work out clear my mind a little
bit now we're back here filming I said
and this is the edited version I'll tell
you the part specifically when it comes
up of what I originally said and why I
change it to this like every single
human being on the planet I'm having an
emotional response right now honestly
the way fandoms can be is quite
off-putting I know not everyone already
clarified that we paid an editor to do a
video for viewers that we knew damn well
wouldn't be monetized and first off I
want to clarify it I want to I want to
elaborate a little bit more on this part
because at the end of this this post I
do say there are sketches we've spent a
whole week working on that were
monetized but we did it because we knew
the people will love them literally
there there are sketches that we will
you know we've spent our shooting and
then like a week to two just editing
through way late in the night like doing
the usual for YouTube patreon and then
after hours just like chipping away at a
sketch and doing that right now for one
and oftentimes it's like like the like
for the sketch we did with Anita with an
order for that bit to work we needed
this song stuck in the middle with you
and I was like this video is probably
gonna get a lot of views and it got like
70 to 80 thousand views which is pretty
good right and I knew this video would
not be monetized and even though I've
spent some money to make this video it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter alright
so and and I usually happens with a lot
of our reactions as well honest as if if
we only put up monetized videos their
behalf the uploads that is just a fact
there only be like two movie studio to
cover a lot of them are not as friendly
about this and the other side to it is
there's a lot of videos that sometimes
we cut up certain parts of the reactions
not to get it and monetize simply just
to not get a blocked worldwide is more
often than not it's it has it includes
copyright content that's why sometimes
we do do sponsorships that's why
sometimes we do push our patreon page to
show that's to get some of that extra
support which all helps we're going
towards the real rejects right so as I
keep going experience this last season
of Game of Thrones hence why most of
these comments are disabled I'm not sure
we want to keep doing reactions for it
cuz it strips the joy away like I said
having a response here criticize me for
not wanting okay let's go besa sure we
don't make money off of it and that's
not the issue the issue is that it's a
free video for people to watch it two
hours submit together and no one who's
in that video is making a profit off of
it we're essentially dedicating time and
money for what so right now the line
that's here is a flashy viewcount or
even a little but subscriber account
doesn't mean as much if on our end the
emotional experience of it is tainted
that's what it says now what I
originally put that rubbed a couple
people the wrong way and I completely
understand why actually was I I said I
said I'm time money for what meaningless
views question mark so I get how that
misconstrued because from there was a
person I think his name is Troy Baker
I basically replied to him on my phone
but my reply didn't show up on my phone
and in the process of trying to make
sure my reply went through I
accidentally deleted his comment so I
left the comment on this post saying hey
if you happen to read this you know just
feel free to leave it again because that
was a total mistake and I'm
acknowledging what you said and how I
know that what I said probably
miscommunicated the whole thing with
saying meaningless views is pretty much
what I meant here because I did follow
it up with saying these sketches spent a
whole week on working that were
monetized reactions as well so if this
experience is gonna be a lot of toxicity
why even bother if anything we were just
gonna do stream along for patreon so my
point was saying that was not to say
that if you're not if our videos aren't
monetized or if you're not a patron then
your view is meaningless that's not at
all what I was implying and and I feel
like most people did not miss read that
I feel like most people didn't otherwise
I hope post would've been filled with
just fine [ __ ] you Greg even though one
of them was [ __ ] you yeah but I wasn't
mad at them for saying that because of
getting upset by it because I was like
put myself in their mindset and like
yeah I probably maybe I might have
misread that so my whole point with that
is I just don't not everything's about
views with what we do not not everything
is about some people we know by views
not not people I actually know I've met
people who've done that some people
really just care about getting a high
view count and they can give two shits
if the if the video has more dislikes
than likes because they're like doesn't
matter I'm raking in those views and
honestly there's a part of me that
wishes I could just be that I don't care
I don't care that has a lot of uses yeah
I wish I I wish I could be more like
that guy because I feel like my life
would just be a lot easier because that
comes with the territory of there's like
a weird line there I think of having
that shark --is-- business mentality
yeah at the same time the benefit of
that is not caring what other people
think about you you know it's hard to
have want people to like you yeah so you
know I used to have much more
challenging people-pleasing qualities
and I've let a lot of that go I still
have some issues with that for sure
so the thing of the same meaningless
news I'm like no that's just not true
there's too
many people pleasing videos that I do
here forgive knowing that it's not gonna
be us anything other than giving the
satisfaction of people who just want to
see this video yes I am you know it's
relevant it's something that everybody's
talking about it's something that we
ought to cover away in on you know be
yeah because we know that there are
people who want to hear about it who
want to see some coverage you know so
there is a back and forth for sure yeah
yeah and when I felt this post I did
mention like I don't know if I want to
keep doing the Game of Thrones reactions
and honestly it's not just today of when
this contemplation came in I was talking
with I can't drop too many names and I
can't drop anyone else's name the saga
with our editor nerd Eric Nura chronic
who knows more people that I do actually
and he was reminding me of things that I
already know like I'm always given
advice too and stuff or I'm well aware
of how you know certain toxicity can
erupt over comments and especially
towards women in the community if the
channels primary demographic is male it
especially comes with this I see it on
screen junkies all like almost every
movie fights episode junkies all the
time I see it up plenty of other
channels that happens here so it's not
just today because a couple of years ago
when we did season 7 reactions it was
already kind of a weird year that
pocalypse that happened I was running
this channel primarily by myself and
then there was a point where we wanted
to start doing patreon and branch out
and then I asked John to partner up and
then now you got what the channel is now
with Jonah Knight so that time though we
did it the season 7 reactions that was a
real thing of I love this show this is
my first year covering this show and I
hate dealing with the toxicity that
comes my way for something I really love
so well half of those videos have
disabled comments just because I was
sick of it now the reason why there's
the comment I didn't disable the
comments years because talks with
YouTube you got to keep the comments up
you got it like
just have to keep the otherwise the sex
video performance well all these things
you know
things to be concerned about other than
just the ship yeah so it was pretty
quick when the video got D monetized it
was like okay yeah that happened pretty
quick so that's why the comments are
still up there and plus the pin comments
that's another reason why I keep the
pink comments are because people read
that more than they actually read the
description box and you know for anyone
who's guessing whether it's Olivia or
shouting out nerd chronic or a patreon
page
we'd like having the pin comment there
and you can't have a pin comment if the
comments are disabled that's why they're
still there just today this post that I
put on the community page wasn't a I'm
so filled with rage it's pretty much the
energy I have right now of just uh you
know I just hate I don't like I don't
like dealing with this I don't want no
rest over a game of Thrones and I
literally it was my fault it's my fault
for reading the comments I got to put
that on me because I'm not gonna change
the way people behave on the internet I
can speak against it you try I can I can
speak against how I hate internet
bullying and all that I hate that people
attack people and not the press I one
thing to attack an opinion it's another
thing to attack a person I like I hate
that you know so it was my fault for
reading because I wanted to see what
people thought of the new style for us
and getting exposed I know what this I
just know what this does to my brain but
I wasn't I wasn't enraged because and I
was so first off I know some people
probably think it's because Olivia was
in the video and that a lot of the
comments were in relation to hating on
her and that's not why I put this post
out first off when it comes to Olivia
how do I put this
she might find this funny and she and
she did she she yesterday she was so she
knew that peachy would get hate and the
thing is a lot of the women that come on
this channel often do if they if they
are
passionate energetic very expressive
ocaña there's a wide variety of reasons
of an energy of a female that rubs
people the wrong way sometimes right and
she's being herself and I'm not gonna
ever ask someone to not be themselves
and I love that she's herself always
always always always there are people
who have come by I've seen it in
collabing with other people on their
channels whatever where people some
often will alter their opinions not be
completely honest and she's not that
person the and the others element with
Olivia she's the toughest human being
I've ever ever known and I don't mean
that in the sense of she gets affected
by this hate but she's gonna come out of
it on tough no she's just not gonna get
affected I wasn't concerned that it is
very low stated yeah I wasn't concerned
that she was gonna be like all
emotionally distraught by this because
it's his wean I know her and anyone who
happens to stumble upon this video and
knows Olivia in person knows that this
ain't gonna mean like there's a few
factors I think about one all these
people can hate on her all they want
talk mad [ __ ] 99% of them aren't gonna
say jack [ __ ] to her face Olivia would
say that she's like if there's any level
of disrespect happening around us or any
level of inequality mistreatment she is
the first person to write down wrong why
she won't speak up John and I well
contemplate you know we are reserved
calculators were like huh what do we
who's everybody involved we're gonna
make this worse I don't want to cause a
scene she's gonna jump in right away and
she like the way how some people can be
like so blunt behind a keyboard huh she
doesn't need a keyboard uh-huh she'll be
she'll say that [ __ ] to your face and
she breaks my autistic children 6 to 8
hours a day hey she doesn't have time
she doesn't waste time with
I'm gonna leave a hate comment on
someone's YouTube video a B this [ __ ]
doesn't matter to her you know like
being a fan of Game of Thrones being the
person who reads the books being someone
who is into comics
she's been a Comic Con more than I've
ever been to come because she's been
more than John has been a comic you know
so she this is just a hobby for her she
leaves a very important job much
important than what we did more
important than what we do and this is
just something she's not fazed by this
the opinions of others do not affect her
literally a lot of people who come on
the show because we're performers and a
lot of us are performers because we want
people who love let's see now in Mass
yeah that as many people love us as
possible
I've learned a lot about her about being
more honest and I feel like as I get
older I naturally get more honest being
with her I become more honest so would
be more honest I'll admit that yeah I
have more people pleasing qualities way
more than my girlfriend does really
percent more and so she she's I wasn't
concerned about that so this post is not
about that but acknowledging what some
people are concluding that I put that
out there because if I'm like no you
there's a reason why you go to our
season several reactions while half
those comments are disabled because it
can if it can get to me of just I know
it comes with the territory I know women
have it harder than we do and in fact
this really isn't a big deal they might
want the days when I was Ryan right
trust me
around then you know I've dealt with
much more I'm talking about years of
[ __ ] way worse than any of this I just
felt like I could put out another
community post I could risk the chance
of saying something that could totally
come across incorrectly but I'd rather
just put it out here yeah just saying
here you know essentially we're all just
trying to enjoy Game of Thrones all
anybody wants here that's all we want is
just to enjoy Game of Thrones you know
so I know I had an emotional response
this morning with the community post and
I do feel like yeah maybe I'm not gonna
be the
who's an idealist to the degree of I can
change the way the internet reacts to
things in the way the internet treats
people I know I'm not going to but I can
go out there and say I really don't
agree with it because like I said I'm a
big believer in attacking the problem
not the person if that comes with me it
comes with John it goes for Olivia goes
ready when it comes on this channel for
example one of the top comments on this
post is from us from a lady who gave a
really good post about me that I though
I should be someone who's willing to
accept feedback and constructive
criticism and is a really really good
post and I replied back to her and the
thing is I do you there if there's
anyone here who's watching who has left
a comment that was critical of something
John or I said or did and we reply back
to you and not a hateful way but
actually talked it out with you it's
because when there is that there we
listen and we will usually if we want to
will reply and will engage with you or
will correct ourselves if you feel like
you know what this person is actually
right I should correct myself I will do
that I mean just for example right now
actually with the person saying what is
it about the [ __ ] what was the phrase I
said wrong meaningless views right but
the person say meaningless views and a
couple people getting upset by that I
didn't attack them back I I read it and
I said you know what I could see how
this miss communicates oh yeah so let me
address it not go [ __ ] you you
misunderstood me you know and the the
thing is when we're talking about this
issue I'm not talking about I have an
issue with being constructive getting
feedback and getting constructive
criticism or disagreeing on an opinion
that's that's not most of the comments
I'm referring the problem is you don't
wind up with a comment section filled to
the brim with constructive critic you
thought process everyone's really had it
you know I really like you Greg however
I kind of disagree with your opinion on
this and here's why it's usually whether
it's the guest or us it [ __ ] you you
guys suck annoying [ __ ] get alive
it's nastiness I mean there's you know
there's a whole lot of different stuff
and every one of the comment sections
but I will say that while it does all
not vitriol necessarily it's not all any
one kind of thing and so yeah there is
constructive criticism but it's all you
know buried in firsts and yeah even
constructive criticism and just
compliment like just there's so much
that yeah ultimately yeah we should be
able to constructive criticism and a lot
of the time the feedback we're getting
isn't actually that yeah you know like
there's constructive criticism which I
always appreciate I always appreciate
feedback positive comments sure whatever
or even if it's a comment yeah like
constructive criticism they don'ts are
why I know there's a silly one that just
kind of makes me go yeah like there
there's ones that I don't agree with
that just I had just shake my head out
like okay they're just kind of silly
like what Nick one of many examples I
can give you is with this TV show
reaction this is a 55 minute episode
right now something like that 55 minute
episode can only show 10 minutes of the
reaction on YouTube and there are
comments of people going you get not
just Olivia like all three of us you
guys just keep talking the whole episode
you guys just keep like I would not want
to watch this episode the first time
with you guys and my thought process
just immediately goes because I took it
to Eric he's like it would actually be
much easier for me to make a 10 minute
cut of you guys not talking cuz it's
reaction highlight show in a certain
point I gotta imagine that you're gonna
want some flavor in there like what 10
minutes do you want do you want the 10
minutes where we're being quiet or do
you want the 10 minutes when we're
giving a reaction to it and yeah it is a
it is we are commenting it's a it's we
know it's we are well aware with mystery
science theater we're going where it's
not your first time watching the episode
we and the ideal way to watch any of
these episodes is not in a 10 minute cut
up space yeah for me we know it's not
your first time we know that and the
whole point is like we're aware there's
a like I don't know what this is we're
some
people expect reaction channels to
completely forget those cameras of light
sported at them you know well is there's
no acceptable rubric for what a reaction
channel is supposed to be so you're
either not reacting enough or you're
reacting too much or you know there's no
way to satisfy everybody and so yeah you
just kind of got it okay we've got it
the react not reacted like last season
there was a moment where it was a casual
line and we didn't really react to it a
rule on no reaction [ __ ] this said
there's no real metric for it the way we
approach reactions is we do come from a
genuine but we always go what we're
feeling that's what we always do we our
approaches whatever we're feeling
internally that you know like what we're
doing like at a theater when we want to
be respectful not make a lot of noise or
whatever we treat it as if like we're
hey we're hanging out with a group of
friends we're aware that there's a
camera pointed at us and the whole point
of it and when we say we're aware the
cam pointed at us and the lights are on
is that we feel like we're watching this
with a group of people even if I'm by
myself I feel like I'm with a group of
people right now I don't feel like it's
only John and I in the room and we're
just hat like yeah it is only John right
technically in this room but I'm aware
there's people watching this yeah so I'm
feel like I'm with a group and that's
the whole point when we're doing the
reaction is like we're doing a group
reaction watch it and when you're with a
group people talk people have chat
people common you know before people let
out what they're feeling there's
supposed to be some kind of communal
some sort of even infectious energy
hopefully yeah it makes the video fun
and then makes it enticing and then
makes you want to stick around and watch
with us as if yeah we're all hanging out
we could do it how if we like to people
who we could do it just the way we do
for movies and shows when were by
ourselves literally is we turn off all
the lights good luck getting a camera
and so yeah but it is it is still
genuine it is still coming from like
that's that's what I always tell people
is like so what am I supposed to do and
I'm like well just be yourself just let
whatever you're feeling internally let
it out
you know just Express that's the whole
point that's what we always say is
express it express what you're feeling
don't talk over
prolonged bits of dialogue we got
express yourself go with what you're
feeling yeah and I'm primarily be
engaged to what's going on but just
express your feelings so yeah like some
of these comments are the cons like that
are just like silly to me like what
would you yeah I'm half tempted it'd be
like let's just roll them and just do
the 10 minutes where we're not reacting
we could be quiet don't do anything
there and stare blankly um see I mean
looking over the community posts
response and seeing that at the end of
the day what I always tell people is
look if people are upset you know those
people usually come it's like Yelp most
people go to Yelp not to praise a place
but to go yeah [ __ ] Starbucks didn't
give me my iPhone this restaurant like
most people will allot I don't know I
can't say most but a lot of people do
and I feel like that's the way it goes
with YouTube comments so even though I
would say majority of the comments on
our video are a lot of hatred there's
some defenders or some people really
praising there's still a significant
amount more likes than dislikes and I
always tell people that go off of that
because more people at the end of the
day if you do the combined total of
likes and dislikes and the combined
total of comments there's always a lot
more combined total of the likes and
dislikes so considering the fact that
the video has more likes than dislikes
significant more and we've seen a lot of
support in the community post yeah well
still continue in Game of Thrones for
you guys because like I said getting
them monetizes is like we're lucky it
worth it's not in our hands
you know with these which are like we're
taking 10 minutes of even though it's
cut up to bits and it's definitely not a
substitute for the actual episode you
still never know what which network is
going to want to claim and at a certain
point fair use they can sort of do
whatever they want so you know we are at
the mercy always when this Gatti
monetized it was for 16 seconds so
whatever 30 second rule you've heard or
20 second rule sometimes it's five
seconds
you go in and you cut that 5 to 16
seconds out entirely and then you
re-upload and there's just a different
way so we're still put it up we still
put it up you know and and the reason we
encourage people to go to our patreon
it's like yeah of course the whole idea
is equal fair exchange it's like we know
that there are channels that have
patreon pages do reactions that have
their stream along reward tier higher
than what we offer and it's just to
compensate the time dedicated to it
because we do reaction highlights for
these things they're not all of our rate
like this video I intentionally said
let's make this one on cuts that way
people know there's no bullshitting
going around like that's why I wanted
this one to be completely uncut I mean
arguably maybe it should but podcasts
but the thing is too is you know like if
you if you watch our format I'll wrap
this up if you watch our format if it's
the giant trailers if we have time to
shoot the intro beforehand we'll do that
and then we'll edit that and then the
rest is uncut but if it's not one of the
rush like oh [ __ ] Star Wars won't you
just drop it you got to do this we'll
always edit the videos and we've spent
on average an hour to two hours editing
the videos before the reaction and after
the reaction cutting those up so we do
make the time dead and a lot of those
videos aren't monetized so you know
that's why we do encourage people to go
to our patreon page and we do think that
we would like to break even fear well
I'm hiring an editor like I've told the
editor that Eric I've said I don't care
a profit I really just want to break
even for what we're paying because we're
doing that you can ask in that or doing
this for you guys so yeah I mean we just
I wanted to get this out of the way get
this off my chest I know most people
don't make it to the end of this video I
want to get this off my chest because
with getting affected by the way this
morning went I wanted to just be let it
go get it out and then go back to just
enjoying the show that I loved you know
that we love we all love we all have a
difference of opinion 600 days it's a
political show
with very in-depth complex characters
that some people will love some people
will hate and that's part of the joy of
it everyone's gonna have a different
opinion I'm letting you know I am gonna
read anymore
don't expect me to read any of those
I'll put on the deep-sea diver suit if
we absolutely need to what's funny is
John is way more of a people pleaser
than I am and yet he reads away for
comments that I find that kind of funny
how your you're able to discern yourself
better than for me where I'm like it's
strange because in real life you have a
much more challenging time with that
than I do comments the only place where
I have a healthy sense of like oh these
people don't know anything about me
really
yeah that's not that big a deal anyway
thanks guys for watching we're gonna
continue doing Game of Thrones and let's
get back to just having fun case